the low literacy levels among us adults
could be costing the economy 2.2
trillion dollars this is on page three
uh a new study of galileo this is a
forbes story a new study by gallup on
behalf of barbara bush foundation for
family literacy finds that low levels of
adult literacy could be cost in the u.s
as much as 2.2 trillion a year according
to the us department of education 54 of
us adults 16 to 74. about 130 million
people lack proficiency and literacy
reading below the equivalent of a sixth
grade wait let me say that one more time
i'm blown away right now according to us
department of education fifty-four
percent of u.s adults sixteen to
seventy-four okay that's 130 million
people lack proficiency and literacy
reading below the equivalent of a sixth
grade level the average annual income of
adults who are at minimum proficiency
levels for literacy level three is below
sixty three thousand dollars
significantly higher than the average
roughly forty eight thousand dollars
earned by adults who are just below
proficiency level two and much higher
than those levels at level zero which is
34. if all u.s adults were able to move
up at least to level three literacy
profession proficiency it would generate
an additional 2.2 trillion dollars of
annual income uh in the country equal to
10 of gdp tom it's unbelievable if you
had read me the details of this story
and said what is the percentage of this
being true i'd say
one percent i'd say there is no way that
this is but it is true and it's it's
incomprehensible 130 that's
over a third of us right now over well
over
335 census and yet you've got this i
mean you know and then you have these
big cities where it's really really bad
you know in la new york chicago san
francisco f's you know they said if
these big cities if if 10
they said the gdp would increase more
than 10 in these big cities if they just
got everybody up to the sixth grade
level that is mind-boggling and here
think about this too what's happened in
the last year kids aren't learning
anything that's right right especially
in big school districts in the big
cities it's a wasted year and it's
probably a wasted three or five years
because they don't care your parents
can't force them to go to school so now
you're raising a whole new generation
that can't read or won't read and it's
the most easily fixable problem there is
i mean if you think about it to teach
people to have you know just remedial
english skills is not that difficult if
the country wanted to you know embark on
it's kind of difficult to get rid of
teachers unions though so
what do you think about this danielle
what do you think about this i think
this is the teachers unions
can you unpack that
look if if covet has taught us anything
it's that the teachers are not advocates
for the students the teachers are
advocating advocates for themselves and
school districts the way that they're
designed the the money goes to the
administration there's way too much in
the way of management you don't pay
teachers enough we've learned that you
can you know
you could theoretically just go virtual
you could go virtual in the classroom
you could hire somebody for a million
dollars a year
a rock star teacher
and have him teach the kids and have him
be engaged kind of like
i don't know a jay leno or something but
just pay him a ton of money and then
teach these kids and you could do that
but you'd have to disband the unions
wait time out you saying that you could
do that virtually because i don't think
kids would no no no no no no no no i am
i am saying that you can do virtual
teaching if you get somebody who kids
are like hot damn
i'm talking about like a rock star
i'm saying deplete the pool of educators
in this country to where you get it to
where you're you're talking about people
who are so engaging that people are like
this is better than tick tock i've gotta
i've gotta go see this person because
you you don't pay you don't pay teachers
enough
and you pay administrators too much and
it's the structure of teachers unions
and they've screwed over children and i
think that they should be i think
collective bargaining should be
made unconstitutional i look at teachers
unions right now and this has only
happened in the last year year and a
half they're a political organization
they always have been though yeah but
they're no more in your face about it
now and it's more evident that that's
their strategy
yeah
and it's all this great inflation and or
deflation or whatever
just let them pass you know give them
trophies for participating i can't
believe this a sixth grade reading level
that's unbelievable by the way let me
tell you why i like this i like this
because
you know it's it's selling me
so so but this is being written by who
can can you look at who wrote this
article who's the person that wrote this
article don't i know it's forbes but i
want to know who wrote it right but you
got to be careful of forbes i thought
foreign
on a report on a big government you know
but go to that article tyler and let's
see who wrote it that's like the usda
report that said that food stamps need
to go by 32 percent
that one
editor's pick michael who is he
is a contributor he's a contributor i'm
a former university president who writes
higher education go google him
google him
uh take his name and just google them
yeah
i don't know maybe i went in college i
was award a phd in clinical psychology
from university of 1973.
all right let's see who you are
as a retired national missouri
university professor
um and prior to that of its province of
uh university of kentucky you have to
retire as president of the terms of
missouri governor jay nixon okay
governor jay nixon i i hope he's the one
who read this 52 minutes ago the
intellectual freedom that made public
colleges great is under threat
no [ __ ] the intellectual freedom that
made public college is great
okay go in washington post go uh by the
way tom who's jay nixon washington post
is trying to do a little bit of cnn
former governor of missouri right i get
that but i mean who is he like what was
he
uh uh okay democratic party he's
probably
[Music]
article right there with washington post
yeah right there click on that
the intellectual frame that made public
college great is under threat uh family
members at public universities are under
fire in numerous states
faculty members at poggle university
the face they face a serious and growing
threat to the academic freedom that lets
them choose their research topics and
determine what happens in their
classrooms without political politicians
looking over their shoulders across the
nation state legislators are proposing
laws to limit the teaching of certain
viewpoints on campus
curb the 10-year system or otherwise
blur the already thin line between
higher education and state politics if
states continue down this path they will
undercut the excellence of their own
institutions of higher education some of
which will currently be counted among
the best universities in the world
they could send these institutions to
down roads right around the gap of
exemption intellectual freedom secure
that private university okay that's good
this is good conversation that they're
having sentence in the last paragraph
there offend the wrong on-campus
constituency and university
administrators will soon be lobbied to
have the offending scholar banished from
campus
this is great but this is great i like
this conversation that guy's got the
right tone yeah to me to me uh i want to
know what the dems and republicans agree
on
what do we agree on can we agree that
china is enemy to state number one yes
okay great can we agree that communism
doesn't work yes can we agree that
socialism doesn't work yes can we agree
that the best social programs are
created by a capitalistic system yes
let's go through these things that we
agree on okay why don't we all let's
disagree on whatever you want to
disagree on who reformed welfare bill
clinton yeah
then then let's go
write these things that we agree on
because the direction this article is
going to edu to challenge people to get
better listen to telling you you go
increase your value in the marketplace i
love that i think that's fantastic that
that conversation is being had so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]